Desertification, is the degradation of a productive,
lush environment into dry, dry desert. Great
for MarioKart and alien planets in movies,
but terrible for growing food.
Planet Earth is a constantly shifting landscape
of 8 biomes, ranging from rainforest to grassland,
desert to taiga. Twenty-two thousand years
ago, the Sahara was pretty much uninhabited,
except for the area around the Nile Valley.
10,500 years ago, monsoon rains rolled in
to wet it up. Climates change, it happens,
and sometimes they change hella dramatically…
like when whole deserts completely shift their
borders… which is happening RIGHT NOW.
Only a few thousands years ago, the Sahara
was green and lush, and now we can't even
IMAGINE it… instead, research has found
the Sahara's shifting sands are expanding,
causing die-offs of vegetation, failure of
agriculture, and increased erosion without
plants to hold the soil in place. But this
wasn't always the case. Scientists had hypotheses
that an ancient river ran through the Western
Sahara, feeding the land and securing it with
vegetation. Clues were left off the coast
of Mauritania, where researchers found sediment
resembling that of a huge river… but there
was no river around, only arid sands. They
called this ancient waterway the Tamanrasset
and now, according to a recent study by the
Japanese Advanced Land Observing Satellite,
it's real!
And was confirmed recently using microwave
radar. If it were still there, the Tamanrassat
river would be the 12th largest on Earth,
winding 300 miles inland (500km) to the Mauritanian
coast.
As the researchers point out, climate change
happens fast. In a study in Earth and Planetary
Science Letters researchers looked at 30,000
years of dust blown from Africa into the Atlantic.
Over the millennia the amount of blown dust
rose and fell in lockstep with the amount
of moisture on the continent; less moisture,
more dust, more moisture, less dust. Today,
because it's so dry, the majority of the sediment
in the Atlantic is from Saharan dust!
It can (and does) reach North America!
By looking at this dust, they know about 6,000
years ago the African Humid Period ended suddenly,
coinciding with an axial change in the Earth's
ORBIT. According to research from NASA and
climate scientists, the Sahara exists, in
part, because the Earth's spin changed, decreasing
Northern Hemisphere monsoons, and causing
the Sahara to grow. Vegetation died very quickly
and the third largest desert in the world
took over North Africa, all in less than 300
years!
In a separate study in the journal Science,
one of the jet streams which moves hot dry
air across the planet's Equator, has shifted
northward, causing the tropics to expand 140
miles northward in the last 26 years; and
with it… the deserts of Earth. Why?
They're not sure, but they know global warming
is part of it, as is the ROTATION OF THE EARTH.
In the movies, when a wizard summons a massive
storm, the storm dissipates at the moment
of his defeat. In reality, when we make huge
changes to the Earth's climate, those changes
are not felt, or easily reversed across multiple
human lifespans. According to NASA's Jet Propulsion
Laboratory, the melting of Greenland ice is
changing the way the Earth spins, changing
the tilt of Earth's axis by 2.6 centimeters
per year, with an increase in that tilt on
the horizon!
Why is the ice melting?
You need only look in a mirror. We live on
a spinning top, and we're messing with the
balance.
SO WHAT DOES ALL THIS MEAN?
To put it simply, as the distribution of ice
and water on the planet changes, the Earth's
axis changes in a process called precession.
Thus, the sun will hit different latitudes
our planet at different intensities than before
-- drastically changing the weather systems
and our overall climate. Whether it's natural
or man-made, the jetstream is already shifting
causing the tropical deserts to expand into
previously lush territory (as we know it has
done in the past), but scientists don't believe
this is a natural phenomenon, it is happening
WAY too fast, and the rates are increasing…
we're doing this.
As desertification hits the American plains,
South Asia, and the Mediterranean, humans
feel the affects through drought, climate
changes, and, eventually, economics. In a
2005 report about desertification from United
Nations University, they state 10 to 20 percent
of these "drylands" have been negatively impacted
through the loss of farmland and biodiversity.
That was a decade ago, and at the time, 2.1
billion people lived in the drylands of our
planet. It's clear, the deserts have, and
will expand, and as they continue to do so,
farmland will dry, vegetation will disappear,
and people will either have to move, or completely
alter their lifestyles.
Now, if you're thinking, "But Trace!
The ocean is FULL of water!
Let's just use that!
You can't. Julian explains why we can just
turn saltwater to freshwater, here. (soundup)
REGULAR DNEWS CTA
There are lots of little things that we can
all do to curb climate change - check out
RacingExtinction.com where you can learn about
things like the five day carbon challenge.
Challenge your friends, your family, strangers,
and most importantly, yourself. There's a
ton of way you can do to make difference out
there. Thanks for watching!
Have you felt the pinch of climate change?
How?